[Música]
si el papel que juega el congreso en
esos momentos
va a tener que reacomodar su relación
con el poder ejecutivo dicho sea de paso
las relaciones que han tenido tanto el
congreso con el gobierno han sido de
conflicto ha sido de conflicto
obstaculizando algunas iniciativas del
entonces presidente de martín vizcarra
muchas veces llamó la atención y se
quejó que las reformas que él planteó
fueron la mayor parte atendidas se ponga
largas en algunos casos alterando la
idea en sí de los proyectos
va a tener que modificar su conducta y
tratar de tender puentes pero más allá
de eso va a tener que luchar por
trabajar
una mejor imagen en una mejor relación
con el ciudadano el ciudadano en estos
momentos no se siente identificado con
su parlamento precisamente están
llegando más ciudadanos que participaron
a estas jornadas de protesta ellos
quieren hacer una vigilia en nombre de
los dos muchachos que fallecieron
durante la represión de la policía son
dos jóvenes que no llegaban ni a los 25
años de edad siquiera y precisamente la
coordinadora nacional de derechos
humanos ha dicho que va a ser una
acusación penal contra el renunciante
presidente de manuel merino el ex primer
ministro ántero flores-aráoz y los
principales representantes de las
de seguridad entonces el parlamento
tiene una tarea grande en delante